this morning in the dish
talent in the kitchen is an important
quality shared by great chefs but
it's not always enough to cook up a
thriving career for some finding a space
to show their talent can seem out of
reach
but an innovative idea born out of the
pandemic is giving them a leg
up by offering them space in a
temporarily closed restaurant
our own michelle miller has this story
from maison yaki in brooklyn new york
jared howard in the kitchen is a man
living his dream so what do we have here
what do we have here we have a selection
of honey bunny's finest
foods a baltimore native his love of
food stems from vacations on maryland's
eastern shore
i love spending time with the family i
love eating crab cakes in the summertime
i've loved hanging out in d.c
but you won't find those chesapeake bay
staples on this menu this right here
this is the corn salad so it's roasted
corn
scallions cherry tomatoes instead you'll
taste
flavor steeped in decades of tradition
this is my tri-color potato salad
it's all in his brand still a concept in
the making
honey bunny's chicken honey bunny is
actually my daughter
started calling our honey bunny out of
the blue when she was like one years old
and i kind of made this restaurant
thinking about her
next to you we have our dipped chicken
you take the chicken you dip it in the
north carolina piedmont sauce
emerging out of this pandemic lockdown
at all has quite
simply been a miracle this is very new
but that's what covet has created right
it's created this environment
where you have to do everything new
right this is innovation
yes it is it is i see it everywhere i go
but in particular
in the restaurant industry there's so
many of us that are on the sidelines
that we have to build partnerships in
order to survive
this partnership teamed him with chef
greg baxtrom
owner of brooklyn's award-winning
olmstead and mazanyaki
across the street this series even came
from
a conversation about how we could get
involved
get involved in growing diversity in an
industry that has lacked it
according to recent data women chefs
make up less than a quarter of the
industry
and just over 17 percent of chefs and
head cooks
are black did you notice that did you
know like
wait where are all the women chefs we're
all the chefs of color
yeah he's doing it by not just offering
them a space which would otherwise sit
idle
i put obey on top of the biscuits it has
a nice little tinge to it
but resources so that now through the
end of october
chefs bartenders sommeliers can rotate
in and out
serving their specialties with their own
unique flair
so why do you do this because you should
if you have the ability to do
i want my parents to be proud of me i
want my sister to be proud of me my
brother you know
it matters to me and and i get joy
in trying to help people it's just been
an amazing amazing experience because
i thought that you know this was going
to be an opportunity to test out this
business concept that i had
it turned out to be an opportunity to
really engage with the community here
and introduce them to my food but also
get feedback how this son of an
entrepreneur
and corporate executive transition from
being a d.c
based federal employee to moonlighting
as a sous chef in the big apple
is quite a story in and of itself the
restaurant culture is huge here and so i
just
fell in love with it every time i went
to a different restaurant it was like
visiting a different country so my spare
time
i decided to start cooking field trips
chef jj
johnson gave him his first shot when he
ran
the cecil i'm very invested in jared and
seeing him be very successful in this
culinary world
what was it what was it about him that
you said this guy gotta help
jared's genuine he's a good guy and it's
really really hard to find good people
i literally talked to him about going to
culinary school and i
asked i said well can you teach me how
to cook and he said yeah come on by
next week and for about a year and a
half two years
cook for him for free i think jared
shows that sense of hope
that there's a new culinary future
coming knowing the work here stemmed
from a growing awareness
of ensuring equal opportunity for anyone
with a vision and commitment to hard
work
african-american restaurants have always
played a critical
role in the civil rights movement we
have sylvia's in harlem
it was where civil rights activists
gathered
and planned marches and strategized one
of the few safe places that we
as african americans had outside of the
church itself
dickie chase in new world yeah dookie
chase in new orleans yeah that
every city that has a major
african-american population has had one
or two of these cornerstone restaurants
and i hope that if i ever get a
restaurant on my own
for honeybunnies to be a place like that
where people can come together
and talk about the issues that are
affecting their lives
and what to do to make it a better place
and with this experience
he's one step closer to getting those
just desserts
it's just delicious we were just texting
with michelle and she said the food is
on the way
[Laughter]
i love the providing opportunity it
always comes back to you have to have
the opportunity to start to build in
communities and people that haven't had
that opportunity it's so important
because the talent
exists the skill exists it's just a
matter of giving that opportunity and
food is on the way